tonight President Trump fighting back
against Steve Bannon saying his former
chief White House strategist says quote
lost his mind
it all comes ahead of the release of a
new book in which ban is reportedly
quoted calling the 2016 Trump Tower
Russia meeting treasonous among other
slights this afternoon mr. Trump
discrediting his former advisor in a
lengthy statement quote Steve Bannon has
nothing to do with me or my presidency
when he was fired he not only lost his
job he lost his mind
Steve had very little to do with our
historic victory doesn't represent my
base he's only in it for himself Steve
was rarely in a one-on-one meeting with
me and only pretends to have had
influence to fool a few people with no
access and no clue whom he helped write
phony books the White House is unfazed
by the latest developments sera Sandra
says this has no effect on the president
his agenda and his base I don't think it
does anything to the president's base
the base and the people that supported
this president supported the president
and supported his agenda those things
haven't changed the president still
exactly who he was yesterday as he was
two years ago when he started out on the
campaign trail his agenda hasn't changed
and he's continuing to fight for and
push for that agenda and I think the
base is extremely excited and happy with
the job that this president has done in
his first year in office look at all
he's accomplished I think they're pretty
happy with where he is okay so
disruptive today to say the least but
you know this coming out kind of a
bombshell because the recent reports
have been the see Bannon was still an
you know good accord with the white
house that he was in communication with
the president but it seems like this was
a direct shot at the president's son
that Don jr. in this book and you see
the president responding like rapid-fire
yeah this is like one of those we all
been there those summer flings an
intense affair and then it just turns to
boiling bunnies once it's over
everything just gets ugly yeah I read
that excerpt and I have to say you know
it's I don't know how much this actually
matters because my take-home from all of
this is nobody there expect
this to happen and and they didn't
change who they were none of these
people change this you mean him getting
elected yes and if so they didn't change
who they were they're the same people
they're not politicians you know and
they're kind of feeling their way and
I'm reading this stuff and I'm going
it's still better than Hillary you have
a choice a businessman who did this as a
lark he did this as a lark or someone
who felt entitled to the job and felt
that she didn't have to do much of
anything and that she deserved it but
then there's a guy who kind of just
waltzed in surrounded himself with some
interesting characters some that maybe
he regrets but I think we can we can
enjoy all this delicious gossip but
ultimately this is a hell of an
experiment this is a hell of an
experiment a non-politician who won in
surprised everybody including apparently
himself and his family and is now doing
a damn decent job I mean I'm sorry but
we've gone through some of these
accomplishments yesterday and yesterday
let's roll that tape but you know what
I'm saying it's like he's actually doing
better than most politicians could ever
hope for that's kind of interesting it's
an experiment that we're all living
through at once it's kind of it's unique
it's phenomenal okay so you're in your
expectation he exceeded all expectations
of people I was I would say at Fox News
I was in the top four critics of Trump
and I it's because I didn't know what to
expect that's relative maybe not stuff
but my point is it's given what we know
about back then and what we're seeing
now it's who cares about that okay
what's your take on it just a different
perspective of dealing with books in
Washington especially when you work for
a sitting president if you think about
George Stephanopoulos when his book came
out during the Clinton administration it
was a really big deal and he was
basically cut off from them for a really
long time with advisers like James
Carville and Paul Begala
basically saying you are dead to us
Scott McClellan during the Bush
administration wrote the book that I was
press secretary at the time Scott had
hired me I was super upset about it
because I knew Washington loves a story
Americans
you dig into it and one of the things
President Bush called me into the Oval
Office and said was I hear you upset
about this book but I want you to worry
about it and I said well can I throw him
under the bus first no I want you to try
to forgive him he said believe me no
one's gonna think about this in three
weeks that could be true here except for
two things one I think that is positive
for Republicans in the long term and one
thing that could be trouble ahead one is
that the severing of ties between
President Trump and Steve Bannon for
good is actually probably good for
continued cooperation for the types of
accomplishments that Greg was alluding
to especially on the legislative side of
things because if you don't have the
constant pushing against Mitch McConnell
and Paul Ryan from Bannon then you
actually allow them to work together and
be able to accomplish things and you
probably don't have to worry about Steve
Bannon trying to primary all of those
incumbent senators that he wanted to do
the thing I think that was eye-opening
about the excerpt that Greg's referring
to that Michael Wolff writes about is
that in one of the quotes Steve Bannon
talks about that the issue real here
really isn't anything that had to do in
2016 it was before 2016 and it's about
money laundering and he talked
specifically about Jared Kushner and
that to me was the one where I was like
I'd pay attention to that if I were them
in the president's statement he doesn't
address any of the claims he does call
him a staffer which is a real burn and I
remember Matt Lauer asked President Bush
when his book came out you know why
didn't you write about Scott McClellan
in your book and President Bush said
because I didn't think it was relevant
and then that's the way that you try to
sort of push these things out of the
spotlight I this will be a story for a
couple of days and it'll probably move
on but that piece that I talked about
the money laundering one was eye-opening
J Jesse I think it's interesting because
the president went out of his way to
make these statements as vicki has past
knowledge information experience where
he had problems with the Bannen etc and
believed some of these things to be
occurring in the past when he was there
right but I know that they still were in
communication once dban and left the
White House yeah I'm surprised he didn't
say I didn't even know Steve ban it's
the stories either fake news or if it's
real but either way it helps the
president because if it's fake the media
shot itself in the foot and if it's real
bannon's weakened and there's gonna be
no more Roy Moore's I read the first
couple paragraphs there's three big lies
Trump didn't want to win Melania cried
when Trump win and Kellyanne Conway
didn't think they were gonna win I know
those are all lies and then you have
bannon's saying that this whole meeting
at Trump Tower was treasonous and then
in 60 minutes two months ago he said the
collusion thing was a farce I don't know
what to think this guy wolf has a
terrible reputation in his own industry
people say he's a gun for hire there is
a complaint that I think the last book
twelve people came forward and said all
of the quotes are true did to me were
completely manufactured well he talks to
quite a few people yeah he talks to a
lot of people but he's got a reputation
for inventing things out of thin air
with that said if this stuff is true and
Steve Bannon said the president United
States his son is a traitor and is weak
and could crack and his son-in-law is
sleazy then not only is that incredibly
disloyal it's stupid and Trump values
loyalty almost above everything player B
being a team player this was something
the mooch actually previewed when he
said what he said supposedly
off-the-record and so if this is true he
has no credibility now going into the
primaries which i think is going to be
good because no one's gonna want to give
him money so that could actually help
the president doesn't have to deal with
any of that primary stuff okay I very
personal level I think that Dana in
terms of the legislative prospects very
astutely and professionally laid out the
impact I they will be a positive impact
the fact that Bannon is now in exile but
yet to brute a you talk about treason
who is the traitor here yeah Steve
Bannon is the traitor this scum how dare
he how dare he I mean what he did to
Donald Trump jr. I mean that that's one
thing I think that the best defense for
Donald Trump jr. in that infamous
meeting at the White House not being
nefarious is that it was so naive there
was no lawyer there so inexperienced you
so overeager over-enthusiastic to me
that's his best defense for Donald jr.
that he
intend to to collude with Russians in
any way that was illegal anyway he
wanted to get whatever information they
could get who wouldn't take that meeting
he was thinking in those days you
believe he said these things I think but
to me the worst thing that Steve Benin
did in this whole episode is to suggest
very strongly that Donald Trump jr. is
sitting in that Trump Tower a couple of
blocks from here surrounded by these
these commies and then after the meeting
Steve Bennett jr. says there is ZERO
possibility he didn't take these
Russians upstairs to meet his fall their
Washington Post in New York Times every
investigative reporter in this nation
has been striving to connect Trump with
that meeting with the Russians and has
failed to do so so now here is Steve
Bannon suggesting you could take it to
the bank zero possibility did not happen
to me that is the and this is the guy
who was his best friend for at least
those few coming on board so yeah that's
why when Jesse when you mentioned that
saying that's disconcerting because
somebody was supposed to be on the same
team you know with the president very
loyal advising him trying to transform
you know American politics and the
Forgotten men and women across the
country you don't do it by making these
kind of very strong statements and and
taking a swipe and trying to take out
the president's son and the family and
essentially the President himself and
he's given the left and the media a
weapon to then hurt the president with
because a lot of these same people have
said for a whole year that the Steve ban
is this horrible person he's this racist
he's this propagandist and now they're
taking him for what he said and using
now it was said he's a truth teller and
they're using this against the President
to hurt them and it was just sad the
whole thing sad and it didn't need to
happen what one quick point Gregg
suggests that President did this on a
lark I've known him a long time he
started telling me who was gonna be
president of United States in 1998 1999
2000 was gonna run as a Reform Party
candidate he wanted to be President more
than he wanted to make money yeah but I
think I mean I believe that he had
doubts the way everybody had doubts when
towards the answer I buy into the idea
that everybody was surprised as for Ben
and I believe he hated the family
because the family provided insulation
from Bannon those were the only people
that were in his way because I think
Bannon saw Trump as a vessel for his own
disruptive principles input and agenda
he wanted to disrupt Bannen globalist
tendencies but he was on stage when the
Bannen is a radical he's a radical he
wants to disrupt he doesn't have mild
opinions every opinion is the extreme
opinion so you know look Ivanka despise
would despise somebody like Roy Moore
who embraced Roy Moore banning so that's
the difference and that's what you're
seeing and she could run circles around
him intellectually so please all right
we're gonna see where this goes from
here let's see check your Twitter
accounts